the photoelectric effect is another one
of these cool things in physics that
sounds like it should be sci-fi but
actually describes an
everyday phenomenon around us this and
related effects are used for
all sorts of things like solar panels
and cameras and the name itself
is the biggest hint into what's going on
photo photon electric
electron so what is the photoelectric
effect
it's the emission of electrons from a
metal
that has absorbed electromagnetic
radiation
like light over a certain frequency
a particle of light is called a photon
and when a photon
has enough energy it can actually knock
an electron free
what happens is that the photon collides
with the metal surface
hitting an electron when these particles
collide
some of the energy of the photon is used
to dislodge the electron
that electron is then shot out of the
metal or emitted
the rest of the photons energy is then
transferred to the emitted electron
we know that energy transfers between
objects and is conserved in a system
so maybe this photoelectric effect
sounds simple
but that's actually why it's such a big
deal so big
that is what albert einstein received
his nobel prize for
why was this such a big deal by
understanding the photoelectric effect
we
also learned a lot about the fundamental
properties of light
today we know that light can behave as
both a particle in the wave
but that wasn't always known when this
effect was discovered
it was clear that light had wave-like
properties
but the photoelectric effect was a big
piece of evidence
that light could also behave as a
particle
it also showed that the energy of those
particles
was related to the frequency of the
light
so how did scientists figure all this
out well let's start by thinking about
how to make a metal emit an electron
this sounds an
awful lot like work and we need energy
to perform work
it turns out that electrons have what is
called a
binding energy binding energy
which i'm going to refer to as eb refers
to the amount of energy needed to pull
an electron away
from the atom that it's orbiting or that
it's bound to
and hence the name binding energy
electrons are happy to remain where they
are unless
something gives them enough energy to
overcome this binding energy
and bounce them out of place so the
energy
hitting an electron has to be greater
than its binding energy
to cause emission
scientists had observed the
photoelectric effect
but they wanted to know how it worked
because well
that's what scientists do so over the
years
various scientists designed experiments
that tested the effects of
different types of light on different
materials
and let's look at what they found
they found that if a light was shining
on a metal and the metal wasn't emitting
electrons
changing the intensity of the light
didn't change things
but they did notice that raising the
frequency of the light did
so for example if you set up an
experiment where you're shining a lamp
on a piece of metal and it's not
ejecting any electrons
shining two of those lamps on the metal
won't change anything
but if you replace the bulb with one
that emits
a higher frequency of light this might
change things
and this was a big hint that light might
be behaving as a particle
why is that if this was a normal wave
we would expect that by sending more
energy at the metal by
increasing the intensity electrons would
gain enough energy to be emitted but
since that didn't happen
it was clear something else was going on
and that eventually led to the idea that
light was composed of photons
and these photons need to individually
transfer
enough energy to an electron that it can
bounce out of place
so by changing the frequency of the
light
we can change the energy of a photon
once this energy is higher than that
of the binding energy we talked about
earlier it can knock an electron loose
any extra energy then contributes to the
energy
of the emitted electron
this is a big deal and enables us to do
some pretty cool things
so let's go back to one of the examples
at the beginning solar panels they have
these things called photocells
which we're pretending i'm drawing right
now and these photocells use a version
of the photoelectric effect to generate
electricity
when sunlight hits the cells they emit
electrons
the cells are designed so that these
electrons moving around
generate a voltage and voltage
can power devices now we can see why the
photoelectric effect is such a big deal
not only did it revolutionize our
understanding of physics
but it and similar effects are used in
tons of technology